[Music]
in quite the typo news submitted by
Chris Rock versus Chris Tucker I take
Chris Rock any day any day Chris Rock
except for in rush hour if he's time i
movies yeah you can't put a crew you
can't put Chris Rock in rush hour
what does Chris Rock up to these days
stand up alright County money I don't
know I can't picture Chris Rock on
Friday though Chris Tucker needs to be
more fulfillment Chris Tucker is a
better a comedic actor but he knows rock
wit standard for sure
a man attended a Christmas parade just
as Satan after a purpose Satan could be
Satan Claus it sounds like something you
would do and then you would just feel
like oh oh no typos you would print it
out - I have the printout right here
[ __ ] you [ __ ] up not me Satan claws
away - I saw his wife [ __ ] picture of
a of a school play everyone was a helps
and one kid was Elvis dressed as elves
today not even the type odors a Ian
they're gonna find an Elvis guy for a
child
piss off like in mid-december yes you
gotta find that mean and put that [ __ ]
up there
they're like foreign parents or
something cuz that [ __ ] reminds me of my
my cousin my aunt told me that when she
had to get like my my cousin had to get
a TV shot she thought she had my little
cousin study TV shows I don't see be
like oh my god to learn good thing it
wasn't a test anyway so this is so this
is pretty low coming into the tea that's
like way out I like this person but it's
like blood you're typing one like your
finger like like goes faster than the
other finger didn't see no one else saw
this before they printed this [ __ ]
editor didn't have it anywhere else
either man spelled correctly not so much
as a comma out of place
conspiracy corner because he's wearing
Christmas because this this typo went
viral and they're like even like on TV
they were talking about it like comedy
shows but yeah and so that's why this
dude butchie's I'm gonna show up as
Satan Santa I'm going to show you guys
the video you should just been saying
you know the Santa Malcolm ation feel
they should have kept it one way or the
other because he's Canadian and that was
like that's a little bit too scary I
just want something like kind of campy
like it's a yeah I want the goat feet
out the spandex thing know what I want
the fool enchilada what are you talking
about
no we're talking the goat feet talking
to Party City devil Carson no I want the
the Halloween Horror Nights like you
might st. Angela he was a $240 costume
with [ __ ]
I want him coming out with goat feet in
the [ __ ] horn
you like goat feet you wanna have to
have like [ __ ] backpack full of smoke
it's going over his head or some track I
want him to scare children
God wants a picture with state you need
to be saying next year now what does he
weigh your street he's got gold feet
apparently he's only got goat can you
screw up anything else about this I just
wanna see the dude shows up with just
like goat feet and like a normal likes a
picture with Jesus it turns out
everybody loves why does he look like
the Hunchback of Notre a dimension go
cats down dogs down even a day later
they practically worship the guy Satan
wasn't an official parade entry the city
wouldn't entertain a late Apple is just
some drunken cover landing Comox as well
we all got our picture taken with Satan
and so did this room it's stepping over
to Satan for Skippy was the perfect fit
they make lots of freaky art I make have
over 40 bizarre hats and rattles the
paper pledges there will be no next year
well [ __ ] captain
anyone know be toy what kind of edited
with that
that's all I'm float it was a great fun
that was a funny cut yeah but yeah okay
scary without the makeup on holy [ __ ]
he's scarier without ya holy [ __ ] why
was that fool like in the crooked ass
Hunchback of Notre dobbs thought like he
was like y'all see my rattle I'm not
just just like Satan today I am selling
rattles as well and aren't working all
the sins other we got 40 whacks maybe
I'd like a spine condition or something
cuz he really is or is just wheezing
character but I only it's only because I
hope I don't think I've ever seen saying
walk like that she reminds me of the guy
on 300 the [ __ ] sellout what guy who
snitched yeah you're supposed to be
thrown out lift but he got saved
testosterone-filled movie I know I never
met didn't manage to see it so an actor
injury yeah never saw so historically
inaccurate nope they would kill their
kids if they went out with it yeah no
well that's what they said right or did
what the defective or defect they kicked
them out but they would actually kill
him the guy that the guy that sold him
out he was a farmer and they were so
tired of the Spartans because what they
would do is they when they would go out
of Sparta and then they would go like
fight other you know armies or whatever
is they would go and rob these farmers
so their neighbors all [ __ ] hated
them oh so when the Persians came in and
they're like alright and then they just
asked somebody like how do we get around
be like I'll show you [ __ ] these guys
yeah that's basically what that guy's
character is dude cost you people have
so much [ __ ] power like when you
think like I was just in Vegas right and
we're walking down the street and
there's like budget Mickey and Minnie
really like janky looking Jake yeah
Fremont Street ones yeah but everyone's
taking [ __ ] pictures with them and
like the kids are all like obviously
like wait you're doing that
[ __ ] where they I mean unless it's
children but sometime
I'll see you like adults do it yeah all
taking photos on my quad you like the
view from Wisconsin you have anything
buried in Wisconsin Braska it's over you
know I think you got to do when you're
in Vegas you can't wait to save up money
thinking move all the way to Vegas and
then take a couple pictures of the
[ __ ] Wolverine and go back what so
relatable I do cuz like the [ __ ]
transformer [ __ ] that they do ballensat
so freakin cool but then like the some
of the costumes though like with
Mickey's like year falling apart
yeah the black is kind of faded and then
you're just like why why these guys dude
my sister was the Easter Bunny in a mall
for a year and my little brother was
like four years old and so she would
like he's she was sitting her lap and
she's like hey hey Kenny I'm the Easter
Bunny it's Jennifer and he's like oh my
God my sister's the [ __ ] Easter but
he had like an existential crisis about
the real one was my yeah cuz this is
[ __ ] awesome he's our slave for like
a year like she's like I'll tell Santa
all this [ __ ] it worked he's like holy
[ __ ] I saw her and I heard her voice I
know that she's the Easter Bunny well
it's real powered cops do people have a
lot of power bull Virginia if you're a
costume what would you try to get away
with over a guy like you honestly I just
want to be an on-field NFL mascot oh
yeah those got so much energy they have
tons of energy and also did you see the
video of Peyton Manning throwing a pass
to like I don't know he's like right
he's a Nuggets game I think yeah yeah
yeah and he Chuck's the ball at the
mascot and if the mascot catches it it's
a terrible video if he just catches it
the mascot misses and then the mascots
going like this and [ __ ] like hit
hitting his knees I just think all thats
all [ __ ] funny be like in a costume
he's actually not only one of the best
mascots in NBA which one is he the
catlin right they've talked about Denver
one I think so but I couldn't tell what
the [ __ ] it was what makes a mascot it
good on our battle on it pain
interactive like I don't think they get
paid much but there's some people they
really enjoy that power and like going
and interacting with fans like the
Warriors ones kind of suck because this
does buff
thrown out t-shirts and [ __ ] the Colts
Indianapolis Colts have the best mascot
in any sport we have this this horse
named blue he's like a fat horse and he
[ __ ] humps everything that's his
gimmick so makes a good man oh [ __ ] he's
just like like that and he turns his
head like this any [ __ ] hump it's
tight that's by far the best in all
sports I challenge you to find a better
mascot yeah I need you see Steve a new
mascot I know I wanted a costume they
let me do it when I was in high school I
got to be in a mascot costume for a
little bit was it hot yeah it's hot spot
remember that a Bronco I think because
it was the Broncos remember the the
Japanese mascot that died oh yeah dad's
too hard yeah - ha it's a dangerous
profession man you got to watch out you
can't [ __ ] around with those yeah you
might overheat I feel sorry about
Disneyland when it's a hundred degrees
summer these guys they have like a
little mini Erica not in Japan when the
when the suit is on though I forget that
there's a human me too so I'm just like
let me [ __ ] pet you dog that's until
they talk to you do it Oh ice - ice -
pull on the chuck-e-cheese tell as it
gets different trick you pull on them
and after I palm like three times it
goes through like don't [ __ ] do that
oh my god so scary do it again see but
that's real power that it could they
could reach you like that and then
you're like holy [ __ ] you know I mean
can you look back at the face and you
pull out is still the yeah at the
plastic yeah but you're in that age
where you think San is real and all this
[ __ ] is real that make you the Chucky
Cheese mouth anything could be real yeah
and so you hear this person and they're
like don't [ __ ] do that or I'll kill
you you're like oh my god he could kill
my whole family yeah do you guys
remember the mouse fight oh it was like
a cartoon yeah so Fievel
we were at the Universal Studios like
they're doing like some like performance
and then he went up the aisle and my
cousin was right here and he took off
his hat and he [ __ ] pet his head like
that and put him down and my cousin got
up and started whaling on his ass
oh my cousin so he's 10 years older than
me I was like ain't so he was like 17
yeah so yeah he was a high school kid
and he was just [ __ ] whaling on the
costume guy yeah and then I was like he
is my hero like that is so cool so funny
whose are the basket my cousin [ __ ] up
the mascot [ __ ] up five volt yeah and
the footage he was stealing characters
cuz he was like this afterwards Fievel
goes west you got a sin it's a true
professional right there
[Music]
[Music]